hi my name is dmitry schloss and i will
be presenting balance allocations within
complete information the power of two
queries this is joint work with thomas
zarwald from the university of cambridge
we will start with some background on
sequential allocation processes
so in this setting we need to allocate m
tasks or balls sequentially into n
machines or bins
and the goal is to minimize the maximum
load
so for this load vector here the maximum
load is 5
and this is equivalent to minimizing the
gap the gap is the distance of the
maximum load to the mean
in a centralized setting this problem is
trivially solved using the round robin
allocation scheme which achieves the
almost
perfect
load distribution at every step
however in decentralized settings we
look at allocation processes that
require less coordination between the
bins
and this finds several applications in
hashing load balancing and routing
the simplest of these process is one
choice so for each ball you pick a bin
uniformly at random and you allocate the
ball there
in the lightly loaded case that is when
the number of balls is equal to the
number of beams
the gap is log n over log log n with
high probability
here with high probability we mean
probability at least one minus and to
the
minus c for some positive constant c
in the heavily loaded case that is when
the number of balls is much larger than
the number of beams the gap is with high
probability square root m over n times
log n
and
you can think of this as roughly the
maximum load of n independent person
random variables with parameter m over
n great improvement over this is the two
choice process where for each ball we
pick two bins independently and
uniformly at random and we allocate in
the least loaded of the two
in the lightly loaded case
this process has a gap of log log n
and if we compare this with one choice
this is almost an exponential
improvement
in the heavily loaded case the
improvement is even more dramatic
as the gap bound remains the same and
this means there is no dependence on m
there are several other processes one of
which is the oneplus beta process in the
oneplus beta process each ball is
allocated with probability beta using
two choice and probability one minus
beta using one choice
mitsumaker interpreted this as a two
choice with uh some probability of
making an error in the comparison
paris uh tulvar invader proved in the
heavily loaded case that the gap is
logan over beta
when beta is sufficiently large and it
is bounded away from one
we are now ready to introduce the
processes that we focus on in our work
so in the adaptive one threshold process
we pick a threshold based on the entire
load vector at time step t
then we sample a bin
if the bin load is below the threshold
then we allocate there otherwise we
allocate in a second being chosen
uniformly at random
so we pick the threshold if the bin is
below the threshold we allocate there
otherwise we allocate to a random bin of
course the second bin would be worse
than the one we picked first
for the lightly loaded case feldheim and
gurelgirvich determined the optimal
threshold and proved that this achieves
the square root log n over log log n
with high probability
they also conjecture that the same bound
extends to the heavily loaded case
for when for the special case where the
threshold is equal to the mean
it was recently shown that the gap is
log n with high probability
a related process is the adaptive one
quantile process
so uh
in this process we pick a three
a quantile
based on the entire load distribution
and if the pin is on the right of the
quantile then we accept
otherwise we take another sentence
it is easy to see that adaptive quantile
process can simulate any
threshold adaptive threshold process by
setting the quantile at the place where
the loads are equal to the threshold
it is also possible using a mixture of
two
threshold processes to simulate any
adaptive quantile process
and it turns out that both are special
cases of the two thinning process
of which there have been several
extensions where you can take up to
these samples
another view of adaptive one threshold
is as two choice with incomplete
information this means that
we can only compare
two beans if
one bin is above the threshold and one
bin is below the threshold so these
beans we can compare
these beans are both above so we cannot
distinguish and these beans are both
below so we cannot distinguish
of course we can also view quantile as
to choice with incomplete information
but here the
the regions are in the rank space not in
the load space so these two we can tell
apart and these two we cannot
uh using this uh incomplete information
interpretation we can extend one
threshold to have
multiple thresholds
and this means we can only distinguish
pins if they're in different regions
so these two beans we can distinguish
these two beans are in the same region
so we cannot distinguish
and ewam and kawashi analyze the lightly
loaded case where when
the thresholds are chosen so that they
are equidistant
in our work we mostly focus in the
heavily loaded case
and of course a similar extension works
for k1 tile
but again the regions are in the rank
space
so in our work uh we disprove the
conjecture by feldheym and girl girovich
and we show that any adaptive one
quantile or one threshold process has
with high probability and omega log n
over log log n gap
and we also
define a k quantile process with uniform
quantiles this means that the quantiles
depend only on the number of beans and
this achieves a k times log n to the 1
over k gap
so for k equals 1 we get a log n upper
bound for k equals 2 we get a square
root
log n
and because of the lower bound that we
have
we get the quadratic improvement when we
use two queries instead of one and this
is what we call the power of two queries
and for k equals three we get cube root
k equals for
fourth root and it approximates two
choice as k increases
in particular for k being uh theta log
log n
we recover the two choice with up to
multiplicative constant factors
and
we also
analyze the case for one plus beta when
beta is close to one in particular when
beta is one minus polyen we show that
the gap is log log n
by majorization we are also able to show
that there is a process for d thinning
which achieves a gap of d times log n to
the two over d
and for graphical allocations in dense
expander graphs we show that
the two choice achieves a log log n gap
and this makes progress towards the open
second of a question by paris albert
vider
our proof techniques make use of layered
induction over exponential potential
functions and we think this will be
useful this might be useful for
analyzing other processes
now we're ready to go in the
proof outline for the lower bound so
we're going to show that any adaptive
quantile and equivalently adaptive
threshold process
has a gap that is at least
log n over log log n
in the first
and log square ten steps
so we consider two cases
first one is that the
the process uses at most n quantiles
that are large
so in this case it means that
we're using mostly small quantiles and
in turn this means that the first sample
is used often
and in particular it means that if we
pick this lower bound to be one over log
squared n
then it means that the process disagrees
with one choice in at most linear
allocations
so by personalization we can show that
one choice has at least
omega n bolt above the
above
m over n plus omega log n
so even if we reallocate all of these
then still we cannot reduce
the gap below logan
and the second case
we have at least n quantiles which are
large
and this means that if we break the
allocation into intervals of n balls
then there will be one which has at
least n over log squared n volts
with large
quantiles and this in turn means that if
we look at the
n over log n
heavier bins then we are doing one
choice over them
and by properties of one choice we get
that the gap is omega
log n over log log n
we are now going to introduce the k
quantile process and give an outline of
the k log n to the 1 over k proof
so this quantile has the median quantile
for coarse balancing
and the rest of the quantiles are placed
in the region of heavy bins
in particular the quantiles are
increasingly dense over the heavy beans
and this is what allows for fine grained
comparisons among them
so in our proofs we make use of the
two-sided exponential potential function
as a base case and this was used by
perestal granviter
to prove the upper bound for the oneplus
beta process
so for each bean
we have um
the exponential of the normalized load
smoothed by a factor alpha
and the second term is the negative of
the normalized load
so for one plus beta alpha was chosen to
be theta of beta
and pdw showed that the exponential
potential
drops by a multiplicative factor when it
is sufficiently large and using this
drop inequality
uh
one can prove using induction
and
the tar law of expectation
that the
expectation of the exponential potential
function is c times n
for
for some c that depends on c one and c
two
and by markov's inequality we can get
that the exponential potential is at
most c times polyen with high
probability
and this implies because each of the
terms of the exponential potential is
positive that the gap is at most log n
over alpha
for small alpha the drop inequality is
easier to prove but the gap bound
becomes worse
in pdw alpha was at most a constant so
the tightest gaps proved there were
of the order of logan
talbot invader uh used this uh as a base
case so the logan gap in order to prove
um to analyze the two choice process in
the heavily loaded case
and they did this
using an extension of the layered
induction
however
we will take a slightly different
approach and we will do this
layered induction over super exponential
potential functions
so super exponential means that
alpha
is no longer is multiplied by a super
constant value
and this is what will allow us to prove
the sub logarithmic gap bands
however we don't
get that the exponential potential drops
unconditionally on every step
we have to condition on this good good
step
which says that the delta k minus jth
quantile value
is at least that small
and
by
again by induction and the tower law of
expectation if we start with the logan
gap bound and we know that in an
interval with the length n times poly
log n
then
aft after that many steps the
expectation becomes linear
and
in order to get this good step condition
observe that
if we know that the exponential
potential is linear not just polyen
then we can get an upper bound on the
bins
that have a load at least
at least some value
and similarly if we condition that phi
jt
is is linear
then we get the good step condition
for j plus one
and this will be the key step in the in
the layered induction
let's see in particular the case for k
equals three
so let's start with phi zero
being linear which implies that the
maximum load is at most logarithmic
it also implies
by looking at the number of bins above
cube root log n
that
the value at the delta 2 quantile is at
most cube root log n
and this is the good condition for phi 1
so phi 1 drops in expectation until it
becomes linear
and it being linear implies that the gap
is at most
logan cube root logan plus log n to the
two thirds which is the dominating term
and it also implies
a an upper bound on the delta one
quantile
in particular that delta one quanta
is smaller than two times log n to the
one over three
and this is the good step condition
for phi two
and hence we get that phi two drops
until it becomes linear
and then we could get the three times
cube root log n upper bound
it remains to show how
how to convert the
expectation of ij being linear into phi
j is linear with high probability
and
we assume that in an interval of length
n times poly log n
by induction hypothesis
every step is good and also we have
every step the expectation of ijt
is is linear
then
by marcos inequality we can get that phi
jt is polyen
in every step
and now we define
psi j t to be a potential of the same
form as phi j
but with uh with smaller constant alpha
and
then phi j
being linear implies that the the change
of psi in one time step is at most cube
root n and this this value
is determined by the ratio between the
alphas in psi and phi
and having this
difference allows us to apply a boundary
difference inequality
with a bad event to obtain that
psi jt is linear with high probability
and we can apply this to every step of
the interval
so to summarize we introduced a k
quantile process with uniform quantiles
that has a gap of k times log n to the
one over k
we also proved a lower bound for any
adaptive one threshold or one quantile
process
and
the
this this shows
an almost quadratic speed up between
one and two queries and we call this the
power of two queries
and for k being theta log log n
we get we recover the two choice upper
bound up to multiplicative factors
and we also get tighter upper bounds for
d thinning and for one plus beta with
beta close to one
finally we apply
this to graphical allocations on dense
expander graphs
for which we prove uh log log n
for for two choice
uh there are several possible extensions
uh for example one could prove um
matching lower bounds for adaptive
k quantile for k being at least two
or prove similar upper bounds for the k
threshold process
and
there
there are several
settings in which
analyzing to choice might be interesting
such as
two choice with noise
thank you very much for listening
you